[Musica]
tra una strada in salita una strada in
discesa
scegli quelle in salita si fa più fatica
ma quando si arriva in alto sia più
soddisfazione e un po la sintesi degli
insegnamenti di mio papà che mi invitava
a non dare niente per scontato non
accontentarmi io vengo da castiglione
olona un paesino della provincia di
varese mia mamma aveva una merceria mio
papà un'impresa edile
avevo un destino più o meno più o meno
segnato la tranquilla apparente
sicurezza della provincia ma io avevo
altre idee
io ho scelto la strada in salita io ho
voluto fare il giornalista
ero ancora al liceo alla fine del liceo
quando ho cominciato a collaborare con
la piantina di varese cronaca bianca
durante la settimana ciclismo
la domenica il ciclismo la mia grande
passione o cosa anche in bicicletta o
corso in bicicletta tra gli esordienti e
gli allievi con la maglia della
gornatese una maglia arancione nera di
lana quando pioveva tanto pesava più
della bicicletta
ero un corridore completo
andavo piano in salita piano in volata
piano in discesa piano a cronometro
ho capito presto che sarebbe stato
meglio scrivere di ciclismo piuttosto
che fare il ciclista il corridore
ciclista allora niente architettura
niente
ingegneria no l'impresa di famiglia ho
fatto scienze politiche gli uffici mi
sono trovato grazie a gino palumbo alla
gazzetta dello sport 2 giugno 1985 sono
entrata alla gazzetta di candido cannavò
avevo un sogno sogno era quello di
scrivere di ciclismo nel giornale di
emilio colombo e bruno roghi di brera di
raschi di cannavò
mi piaceva il ciclismo è lo sport che
secondo me più si presta al racconto lo
spawn uno sport unico uno sport che va
direttamente alla gente uno sport che
non chiede il biglietto 1 sporchi non è
mai uguale a se stesso non è uno sport
che si fa in un palazzetto in uno stadio
in una piscina è uno sport che si va all
aperto
pensate a un giro d'italia un tour de
france le tappe partono da una città
arrivano in un'altra ma anche se fanno
la stessa strada non sono mai la stessa
cosa perché le strade cambiano con gli
anni perché il tempo non è mai lo stesso
il turismo cambia il ciclismo ti
consente di raccontare personaggi che
vanno oltre che hanno storie
straordinarie da raccontare
si dice che lo sport sia una metafora di
vita se non lo è è qualcosa che gli
assomiglia molto io penso che il
ciclismo in particolare sia qualcosa di
più sia la rappresentazione della vita
sia qualcosa che appartiene alla vita in
francia che sono cultori di ciclismo
quanto noi hanno un modo molto semplice
esemplare di raccontare il ciclismo
suddividono la tattica ciclistica in tre
momenti
in un primo momento del peloton il
gruppo quando si parte tutti insieme poi
ci sono i curare sciape i fuggitivi
e poi ci sono gli inseguitori e voi
pensate alle nostre vite in qualche modo
a tutti noi può capitare di essere quasi
sempre gruppo o di essere attaccanti re
staker in qualche modo sognatori o di
essere inseguitori e sta a noi decidere
quando attaccare quali inseguire e
quando restare nel gruppo perché a volte
facciamo il passo più lungo della gamba
attacchiamo quando non è il momento
giusto e ci ritroviamo a non tenere
nemmeno le ruote del gruppo perché vi ho
fatto questa lunga premessa perché
voglio raccontarvi oggi due storie di
due grandi campioni di due fuoriclasse
che in qualche modo sono stati ri
stecher
hanno fatto qualcosa che va oltre se c'è
una cosa importante nello sport e la
capacità di sorprendere dello sport la
capacità di andare oltre e nei miei
ormai 35 anni di carriera mi sono
imbattuto in tante situazioni in cui i
campioni i nostri campioni più amati
hanno fatto qualcosa di sorprendente
sono andati oltre
voglio raccontare nei due una a cui ho
assistito personalmente l'assenza alla
seconda e una invece che mi hanno
raccontato che ho visto nei video che ho
letto sui giornali mi hanno raccontato i
testimoni di quel giorno e fate chiudete
gli occhi fatto un salto indietro di
oltre 70 anni 10 giugno 1949 giro
d'italia in maniera sace dolfo leoni un
velocista nel menù di giornata c'è la
cuneo pinerolo una tappa straordinaria
250 km 5 grandi montagne il colle della
maddalena vars l'izoard il monginevro il
sestriere coppi sa che quello può essere
il suo giorno il giorno della grande
impresa ha un rivale che rivale di
sempre gino bartali la sera prima a 3
celle il direttore sportivo che chiede a
coppi che cosa preparare per il
rifornimento dei gregari dei compagni
coppi dice pane salame e lanternino a un
progetto a un'idea la corsa parte cuneo
piove freddo nevischio sui sui colli
parte da parte la corsa all'attacco
della prima grande salita della
maddalena bartali fora coppia attacca
mancano 192 km coppi pensa dentro di sé
troppo presto forse attaccato troppo
presto ma mai andata ma ormai
all'attacco bartali pensa a questo è
matto ma doveva troppo presto ma non ha
altra scelta deve inseguire sulla prima
salita con pin testa batte
dell'inseguimento ci sono sette ore di
straordinario inseguimento uno contro
l'altro su ogni salita a vars izoard
monginevro sestriere un testa a testa
tra i due che sono i più grandi rivali
di sempre nella storia dello sport
italiano
bersani giornalista francese racconta
per darvi l'idea di quanto sia stata
storica quella tappa
segui inseguivo coppie ad un certo punto
traslarsi l'izoard mi serve in una
trattoria più o meno
la zona di barcellona ed entrò in
trattoria ordine un pasto completo
dall'antipasto al caffè mangio tutto con
grande calma fu una sigaretta esco
passava il sesto quella è una tappa
talmente importante che lascia il segno
anche nella storia del nostro mestiere
maria ferretti il leggendario
radiocronista e in quella tappa che dice
una delle frasi più iconiche del nostro
mestiere dice un uomo solo al comando la
sua maglia biancoceleste il suo nome è
fausto coppi coppia arriva al traguardo
di cuneo con quasi 12 minuti di
vantaggio su bartali quasi venti minuti
su un gruppetto regolato da alfredo
martini il grande alfredo martini a
milano vince il giro d'italia il suo
terzo giro d'italia quella per tutti noi
è ricordata come l'impresa delle imprese
come la tappa delle tappe del giro
d'italia
se coppi e il leonardo del ciclismo
quella è la sua gioconda 50 anni dopo
sempre a giro d'italia 1999 un altro
omino a pedali marco pantani si trova in
una situazione che non aveva mai
capitata la tappa quella racconigi
europa l'arrivo in salita e adattissimo
a pantani i pantani è per tutti noi che
abbiamo seguito il ciclismo l'emblema
dei ris taker l'attaccante per natura
quello che non sa stare nel gruppo non
sa stare nell'omologazione che deve fare
qualcosa di sorprendente ogni sua
vittoria è stata un'impresa
quel giorno a tutta la mercatone uno
davanti che il che lo tira ma
all'attacco della salita 8 km dal
traguardo succede quello che non deve
succedere
salta la catena ha un problema con il
cambio parte né si deve accostare alla
destra della strada perde 35 secondi
quaranta riparte da fermo
complessivamente almeno 50 secondo un
minuto davanti a sé a 49 corridori lui
il più grande attaccante lui il
fuggitivo si trova ad inseguire deve
inseguire recuperare tutti questi 49
corridori si fermano i gregari come uno
alla volta borgheresi velo podenzana
garzelli zaina tutti trenino
pantani riparte all'impazzata non sa
come fare
sentiva che la soggiorno ma si trova di
fronte a una situazione difficile lui il
grande attaccante deve inseguire rimonta
una alla volta tutti gli avversari si
ricorda di quando era ragazzino quando
era un allievo era talmente forte in
salita e che aveva il gusto quasi sadico
di farsi sfilare in fondo al gruppo per
recuperare una alla volta e vincere da
solo
quella volta lo faceva per scelta questa
volta non ha scelta
insegue tutti a 3 km dal traguardo li
abbia presi quasi tutti ne rimane uno
laurent gialla berg il campione di
francia raggiunge anche lui appena lo
raggiunge lo supera e di nuovo lui
pantani da solo
vola verso il traguardo vince anche
quella tappa pantani non è avuta
giornate migliori e dato anche più forti
in alcuni giorni al cera al tour ma quel
giorno al fatto una cosa che è andata
oltre ogni aspettativa ha superato anche
se stesso allora noi non possiamo essere
tutti coppi non possiamo essere tutti i
pantani ma nella vita di tutti i giorni
possiamo scegliere ogni giorno in ogni
minuto della nostra vita se essere
attaccanti inseguitori o se restare nel
gruppo nel peloton se la vita è un
viaggio
io voglio farlo in bicicletta in salita
naturalmente si fa più fatica ma si
arriva in cima
se ha una vista migliore e poi c'è la
discesa